[Applause]
all right scum and villainy
it's two two two two two
let's welcome kevin smith and mark
bernard to fat man beyond
[Applause]
welcome back to fat man beyond i'm kevin
smith i am mark bernard
[Applause]
we just gave each other kova doing all
that man
uh welcome back kids uh here we are in
the real uh world we're both coated up
because it was very chilly in the green
room uh out back it's cold in los
angeles and [ __ ] we might as well be
doing this [ __ ] show in jersey
weather's not what it's meant to be and
[ __ ] before we get started kids uh i'll
forget if i don't do this uh we got
birthday in the house uh tonight
who's birthday
steven silva is your birthday where are
you where are you where who else are you
where are you
over there
stephen
welcome man hold that thought it's your
[ __ ] birthday too
happy birthday it is your birthday
oh hi what's your name
mike any other birthdays
who's me you in the back
are you serious
holy [ __ ] all we know when all of your
parents [ __ ] man
all we have to do is count back nine
months man mark do the math what is it
no no
what's your name
byron
all right so we got a byron we got a
mike
ladies and gentlemen uh years ago we
couldn't do this because uh allegedly
warner brothers owned the song and then
thanks to
a landmark lawsuit that proved they've
never owned the [ __ ] song
we can all sing happy [ __ ] birthday
without fearing [ __ ] bugs bunny
coming through the door so here we go
ladies and gentlemen
on behalf of stephen mike and byron will
get all their names in the [ __ ] song
let's do it count of one two three
happy birthday to you
happy birthday to you
happy birthday
stephen mike and byron
well
done happy birthday
to
you
[Applause]
god i just that was it i lost all my
[ __ ] breath on that one yeah i'll see
you later have you had a good show
tonight we're going home i felt like i
thought i was whitney houston for a
second there and i really
really went for it with lungs i don't
have [ __ ]
instead you were fergie and it didn't
work out so well
i guess it was kind of fergie um welcome
everybody we got a bunch of [ __ ] show
uh for you tonight
if i am uh quiet
and expressed no opinions whatsoever it
was because the last time we did this
show i made the mistake of saying that
you know with 10 oscar nominations i
think it's weird that spider-man didn't
get one and [ __ ]
and then three days later i was treated
like [ __ ] hitler on the internet man
so [ __ ] bad i saw [ __ ] people
tweeting [ __ ] like you should have died
with your heart attack
people were [ __ ] i'm serious people
were [ __ ] mad man like as if it was
outrageous hot take or something like
that so i had to deal with it for a good
i don't know 24 [ __ ] 36 hours and
[ __ ] and then
72 hours later the academy came out and
said oh we're to let the audience vote
on an award so that spider-man could get
a mention and [ __ ]
so you know [ __ ] i if if i seem a
little circumspect tonight is because i
don't want to get yelled at by strangers
for suggesting that the movie could have
been nominated not win [ __ ]
like there's no way should win you're an
[ __ ] i was like i didn't even say it
could win or should win but i was like
when they extended that category of best
picture
from five nominations to ten it was
after the dark knight
and it was because they were like the
dark knight should have been [ __ ]
nominated we only had five slots in the
future we're gonna extend it some more
popular films can [ __ ] get nominated
and so i mentioned on the podcast like
oh you know [ __ ] they are they gotta
include more populist films if they want
people to watch it [ __ ] then a bunch of
[ __ ] film twitter just came for me
bro holy [ __ ]
like i had no recourse and [ __ ] it
wasn't like hey i made clerks like [ __ ]
you they just
you know nolan i was like i know but
they came after me so [ __ ] hard for
suggesting that it could have been one
of ten films
nominated for [ __ ] sake so if i don't
talk a lot tonight if mark does most of
the talking and hopefully he has a fiery
[ __ ] opinion that makes the internet
mad at him
it's only for that reason oh well i had
some love the week before you decided
spider-man was good what happened to you
oh i had feelings about joe rogan um
and i'm not sure if you've been on the
internet when you have feelings about
joe rogan how was that
oh sweet
you and me gotta stay off the [ __ ]
internet man but obviously like with the
[ __ ] with the spider-man thing it
wasn't even a hot take like i could see
if i was getting political i could see
if i was talking about vaccines and [ __ ]
like that
literally [ __ ] just going like uh hey
man couldn't spiderman have been one of
the nominations and people were like
[ __ ]
just
out it was outrageous dude like i i
didn't cry
but
i did go to sleep at four in the
afternoon where i was like i hate this
[ __ ] world
cuddled up with [ __ ] shecky it was
just like a sad wank and a nap and then
that was it jesus christ man
well i didn't jerk off i was too
depressed to jerk off do you guys
jerk off
i only jerk off with joy i don't do it
out of a sense
talk about privilege
holy [ __ ] oh that's a whole other thing
i put up a tweet about that too where i
was like hey man uh somebody suggested
that i might you know i thought i was a
self-made man and they suggested you
you're a creature of privilege and i was
like thoughts and i shared no opinion
one way or the other fair and it was
divided i wouldn't say evenly but very
divided between people who were like i
would say 40 and up who were like damn
straight yourself made man and then
every [ __ ] gen z or millennial on the
planet going you privileged [ __ ]
coming down to this is the one i would
like to throw out there just to see if
i i did come in for a world of privilege
did you have access to credit cards when
you were like in early college like 19
20 21 didn't did predatory lending go
after you like it went after me um
yes
so when did you have your first credit
card probably
23 i think and it went badly like a late
bloomer man
it went badly that's why they didn't
give you a [ __ ] credit card
yeah they were not they were not jumping
to give me a credit card because
credit is not a thing that often gets
extended to certain populations is that
what it comes down to
yeah so even predatory lending like
stops at a color line where they're like
look we'll get anybody except them there
are algorithms at work are you serious
yeah well then i guess i am privileged
because i i went into the world of
filmmaking with a fistful of credit
cards none of which i ever used
in my life prior to making the movie but
i got them over the course of a two-year
contest with brian johnson we were going
to brookdale community college and [ __ ]
and like you know i i can't speak for
brian but i grew up [ __ ] broke-ass
poor ch so it's not like they were like
oh here's somebody with money and [ __ ]
but every [ __ ] junior college kid
they would inundate you with
applications for credit cards and stuff
and and no maybe my memories incorrect
sometimes you would just get sent a
credit card in the mail even if you
didn't [ __ ] apply for it so
i guess that is privilege so
so
so i you know i would fill out one day
me and johnson were like [ __ ] let's
have a contest to see who can get more
credit cards the fastest
and i was like all right and i had no
intention to use them because my parents
were like credit is the devil cash only
and [ __ ] like that it always been beat
into me but i was like [ __ ] it for a
contest i think i can get this i think i
could win because i worked at [ __ ]
quick stop and rst video you had a job
and i had a job but i would also write
on my application i was the manager of
rst video and i made 50 000 a year this
is 1989. [ __ ] yes so what happened you
could have bought highlands making no
[ __ ] i was a magnate on paper what
happens is they call up to do a credit
check
and so i was the only person ever at rst
so when they called they were like i
we're running a credit check on kevin
smith i was like oh my manager he makes
50 000 a year
and they were like good enough click and
that was it and i get sent a credit card
so i beat brian johnson he got four and
i got 12. and i never [ __ ] touched
him just stacked him up and left him in
my underwear draw never had a [ __ ]
use for him and again my parents were
like every time my mom saw one come in
she was like don't do that nothing good
comes from credit cards like something
must have happened to them early in
their lives which they never told me
about somebody came and collected the
vig from that first credit card i guess
but that was it like i i couldn't have
made clerks without that dopey stack
of [ __ ] credit cards but what you're
telling me right now is the fact that i
even had a dopey stack of credit cards
which i took for granted is like oh my
god every teenager and [ __ ] early 20
something in the 90s got that because
everyone i was surrounded by
got it but now i realize that everyone i
surrounded by mark didn't look like you
at all so
you know i'm starting to catch on to the
game mark i was just going to let you
find it
and you did
i appreciate that
you did
but the thing to remember is that it's
not your fault
you did nothing to gain that privilege
it's not like you were hey good thing
i'm a white guy i'm going to get a bunch
of this [ __ ] this the world was a bit
easier
and it was a bit easier because i wasn't
like that good kind of white where
they're like this way monsieur
you aren't the eddie murphy and white
face kind of white
yes
there's a separate barbecue when i saw
that sketch i was like no way not my
world
um but in any event we're gonna stop
doing hot takes so this is gonna be the
softest [ __ ]
show you ever heard it's going to be
like hey uh you know dc's doing a thing
isn't that great it's going to be the
the asmr of podcasts yes
what does it sound like i'm talking if
you tuned in to be like let's get some
more hot takes from these [ __ ] man
burn down the oscars [ __ ] nothing
nothing like that this week however i
will say this
don't do it i just saw a [ __ ] tweet
where the oscars are not going to be
broadcasting certain categories that are
going to be awarded now that happens
every year usually some technical [ __ ]
they give off camera where they're like
some [ __ ] invented a microphone
we gave him a [ __ ] oscar you don't
need to know about it you know and they
show a clip of some old guy shocked on a
stage
[Laughter]
somewhere weeks ago and [ __ ] so that's
standard but generally you know the big
categories that are required to make a
[ __ ] motion picture that these awards
celebrate and stuff minus spider-man
um
still sticks in my craw couldn't resist
they uh they've announced the categories
that won't be on television this year
and some of them i i feel are like what
how can you not do that
one is film editing
which is like in the art of filmmaking
[ __ ]
editing you're not going to show that
category but that's me as a filmmaker
and i don't even consider myself a
director i consider myself an editor
first it's easy and wonderful and
convenient because the critics they
don't consider me a director either but
i always consider myself a an editor
that just happens to direct his own
films so i'm always interested in
[ __ ] editing and i know how crucial
it is to the process to have them be
like we're gonna do that off camera that
to me is like as a director i'm like
that's [ __ ] weird as a filmmaker i
said that's weird the one that's really
[ __ ] weird though
that i'm like you're not gonna do that
on camera is best score
which like our whole lives growing up
but i realize
that we're maybe responsible for this
our whole lives growing up watching this
stupid [ __ ] show they do a dance
number and you're like oh [ __ ] i'm going
to take a [ __ ] and you'd leave the room
and [ __ ] like you didn't care and
somebody who didn't sing the song was
singing the song if it was up for best
song or whatever the [ __ ]
and now i guess they listen they're like
[ __ ] it we're not going to show your
best score and i'm like what now we're
not get to see that that's going to be
given in a separate ceremony and they'll
do a kind of clip package of like this
is what happened a couple weeks ago but
those two categories would you agree
should be if you're doing a show that
celebrates
the art of cinema and i really [ __ ]
hope film twitter and i can see eye to
eye on this one don't you think at least
those two categories if not production
design which was also [ __ ] something
we're like well we'll do it a few weeks
before the ceremony they're leaving them
off thoughts i think and i think we've
said it before in the podcast i think we
might even mention it last week when we
talked about john williams and his 90th
birthday
that i think john williams is the single
most important person in film in the
last hundred years in that if that
person doesn't exist
none of the movies that we love
we love them the same way that's true
because that music is integral to the
development of a generation or two of
movie fans yes imagine if jaws was just
like oh baby
not nearly as terrifying steven
spielberg doesn't have a career but i
want to see that cut now [ __ ] yeah right
[Laughter]
but yeah it's it's it's boggling to the
mind that they would take
especially those two that are tenants of
the way movies are made um and decide
that we don't need to hear the speeches
of those artisans and that's ultimately
what it is we're trying to cut down the
running time so let's take off the
speeches from people that we won't
recognize
and just let [ __ ] brad pitt talk for
longer or let's let anne hathaway talk
for longer or benedict cumberbatch who
will probably win a thing
that's right because he's up for years
because he's that perfect i mean so like
from a production standpoint i
understand it i think it's awful because
be what you're supposed to be which is a
celebration of the people who make
movies and these movies this year and
these are the way you make movies we're
celebrating it every step along the way
[ __ ] that
and also [ __ ] the weird like people's
choiceification of the oscars of like
hey twitter write in what you'd like us
what name you'd like us to say on the
broadcast like [ __ ] you i didn't come
here to hear twitter's thoughts
about it
[ __ ] you twitter
[Applause]
they're coming for you
[Music]
do your best
um batman did i hear you try to banff in
earlier
give it up for banff man everybody look
who it is
it's jc
yeah i uh when we were you were talking
about predatory lending yeah i was
wondering when you guys were in college
did they like offer like sign up for
this credit card and get a free t-shirt
or get a [ __ ] yeah get a uh like pair of
sunglasses yeah something like that that
marlboro miles fueled my [ __ ] early
20s
yeah i just remember signing for like 20
cards because i was like that's a cool
shirt oh i need a pair of fake oakleys
yeah and i was [ __ ] white guy right
i mean oh privileged [ __ ] whatever
no i was that way with magazine
subscriptions like if you were gonna
give me a shirt or a hat or a phone then
i probably
sports illustrated or whatever like i
don't give a [ __ ] but you gave me a
football phone
i had an extension in my room but i got
a phone i remember that and i wasn't a
sports fan but i was like that's a cool
phone i might subscribe just for that
you had it yeah didn't have a line in my
room
but i had the phone
it was an optimistic phone it was like i
guess
one day i'm gonna have my own place
where's the [ __ ] phone now i don't
know you're a grown ass man with your
own house you could be plugging it in
like now i have a line
um hey we got sponsors we do we have to
pay the bills kids so we welcome we
don't curse sponsors around here [ __ ] we
love sponsors and this sponsor we love
they're always [ __ ] giving us money
for the show which says to me
that the audience must stink because
apparently they need their product we're
talking about the good folks at native
give it up for native ladies and
gentlemen
[ __ ] native man i i see these
products like crazy uh because once they
come into the house my wife absconds
with them once they run out she re-buys
her own she [ __ ] loves
native i started using deodorant again
recently i stopped like 25 [ __ ] years
ago or something like that
it wasn't some like charlene woodley
thing it was just i had a girlfriend who
was just like
yeah yeah but yet you've never smelled
me right
no
no i haven't i had a girl because the
weed overtakes everything else that's
true that's right
i do kind of wear a deodorant i just
happen to smoke it instead of roll it on
but native i started using because
around christmas time they put out the
candy cane flavor
which was legit [ __ ] smelling good
and then they put out the [ __ ] um
the butter cookie flavor which was
tasty as [ __ ] man yeah and then my wife
at one point we were like fooling around
she was just like what smells like food
i was like that's right i've gone native
[Laughter]
um they've been a sponsor of the show uh
for such a long time man and it makes me
think that the only reason they would do
that continue the sport is if folks here
are buying native so thank you to
anybody who listens to the show go to
native dot com is that the address
native deo that's it dot com the d e
slash fat man
nativedeo.com it's right up there on the
screen holy [ __ ] i could see the [ __ ]
it's like a telethon i feel like jerry
lewis
look at the graphics i remember when
this show didn't have [ __ ] like that
well done bath man give it up for banff
man everybody
banff man and [ __ ] the unsung hero
andrew in the back give it up for andrew
you don't see him but he sees you
what are the good folks at natives
saying this week mark
if you haven't tried native deodorant
here's what you need to know it's
[ __ ] dumb there [ __ ] i finished
the copy for them well done and we're
done uh
it's aluminium free yeah i like to say
it that's the british way i know it
makes me feel fancy
offers 24-hour odor protection is vegan
and cruelty free that's why i eat it
hidden with naturally derived
ingredients you can choose from over 10
cents so don't sweat making that switch
from antiperspirant to a deodorant with
over 1500 five-star reviews native will
keep you feeling fresh all day long
don't stink kids go to nativedeo.com
is there a fat man thing there is but
smell and feel fresh all day long with
native get 20 off your first order by
going to nativedeo.com 20 i know right
man
nativedeo.com slash fat man or use promo
code fat man at checkout that's native
deodorant weird going to a [ __ ]
deodorant site and [ __ ] clicking fat
man they're like oh we know
that's why you're here yeah uh slash
families promo code fat man a checkout
for 20 off your first order there it is
we thank the good folks at native
uh give it up for nativedeo.com
[Applause]
uh how are you what's been going on in
your life man i saw on twitter that you
[ __ ] a thing went away a thing went
away um you got to say what it is yet or
not yet i can't say exactly what it is
or who it was with other than there's no
kids there's no protocol
on something like this when you're
involved with a project that dies
um
there's nobody ever says like you know
you are or you aren't allowed to say
[ __ ] i think it's self-governed we tend
to not want to say things
keen hopes that it might find life
in another place and stuff but that's
the only reason he's going to be coy
about this
just because it could wind up coming to
life some places there's always hope yes
but i was supervising a couple of
writers on a pilot that was going to be
for amazon that ultimately amazon
they were not in the business of making
the kind of show that we were making
would they run out of money uh no but we
were not going to make them lord of the
rings money
like
could you make them any of that reacher
money holy [ __ ]
[Laughter]
did richard scratch all your riches uh
like literally what a great review i
told my friend ernie o'donnell uh he was
like i watched the new texas chainsaw
with my wife and she called me an
[ __ ] and walked out
and i said [ __ ] then you gotta watch
reach her with her bro and he goes reach
her he's like the tom cruise movie and i
was like no man they did a whole ass
show
on amazon called richard and the guy's
[ __ ] giant and he's based on the
books i said mark told me to [ __ ]
that he liked it and i [ __ ] you know
one night i was sitting there with jenna
i was like mark says reacher is
watchable and he was right about that
other [ __ ] show with matt mickelson
that movie ah writers of justice [ __ ]
writers of justice i was like let's give
it a roll
this [ __ ] reachership
is so
[ __ ] satisfying every episode is
satisfying the whole i can't think of a
better word for it man it's like batman
with no cape that's it he just [ __ ]
rolls around punching [ __ ] and
killing them
there's one [ __ ] scene in reacher man
that like blew my [ __ ] mind it was so
small throw away nobody probably
thinking about it but me but it really
captured my imagination probably because
i was so [ __ ] baked when i was
watching it
reachers like you know tricks a bunch of
[ __ ] into coming to a house and
they're gonna kill them but [ __ ]
[ __ ] richard gets killed by nobody
he's gonna [ __ ] turn the tables and
kill their asses right so they're all in
the house hunting for him and [ __ ] like
that there's one guy in the getaway
truck just sitting there you know the
wheel man and [ __ ] he ain't killing
anybody but he is involved with bad
people so [ __ ] you you had a job by
association guild by association so he's
sitting there in a [ __ ] car man and
then this happens in the span of i kid
you not five [ __ ] seconds
he looks over [ __ ] reachers right
outside the driver's side window with
you know military [ __ ] face paint
closest you get to a mask but he was so
[ __ ] badass
and he looks at him dude has no time to
react before [ __ ] reacher punches
through that [ __ ] window
grabs that [ __ ] guy before he can get
his gun slams him on the roof and starts
pulling him out and this dude's [ __ ]
struggling and [ __ ] like that and he
gets him right on to the [ __ ] ground
and the dude like this is not this is me
projecting on to the dude but like four
seconds he must have been like what the
[ __ ] who the [ __ ] why did he break the
what the [ __ ] get off of me ow and then
he pulls him onto the [ __ ] ground
your face down on the ground and in your
head you're like i'm gonna get up and
kill this [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] i gotta get
before he could have a [ __ ] the
thought could conclude
reach your [ __ ] steps on his neck and
breaks it
and i [ __ ] died i was laughing so
hard i was like that [ __ ] poor piece
of [ __ ]
he did not know the lord was coming and
the lord was named a reacher man he just
reached in and pulled that [ __ ] out
and curbed him holy [ __ ] i ain't seen a
more satisfying show
in a long time as i put it up there with
peacemaker in terms of the [ __ ] body
count it's crazy
this is wonderful who's the guy that
plays him do you know alan richton
give this guy a [ __ ] award he should
be nominated for one of the 10 best
picture films there there's your hot
take for the week
there's [ __ ] alan richton yeah us
down he was in smallville years ago he
played like aquaman he was in the titans
he played the
hawk
hog hawk um [ __ ] he's good man he's just
like
number one he's [ __ ] huge and so
everybody reacts to him the way they
should they're like jesus you're big and
[ __ ] he's already intimidating and he
could kill like [ __ ] 96 ways before
you can finish your breath and [ __ ] like
a he's a good guy got a moral code and
[ __ ] doesn't seem racist kills everybody
don't [ __ ] matter
you know [ __ ] real just satisfying
that by up i was like [ __ ] man here's
the best review i could give it if i
could dig up my father my dead father
has been dead for like almost 20 years
and [ __ ] number one to be a miracle
because we cremated him but if i could
dig up his body and [ __ ] sit him in
front of the tv to watch reacher it
would literally bring him back to life
because this show was made for my father
it is very much a dad show you would
think right no it's not i would think
like those books
those books are dad books and yet my
wife sat there and watched every episode
with me and remarked on every episode
she's like i shouldn't like this show
but i like when he kills these people
and i was like isn't it [ __ ]
satisfying like that should be justice
right there man i i think the key to
reacher's appeal what is it why do i
love it so much is that it's very much
about the power fantasies of a man of a
certain age
like
this ain't another privilege
conversation isn't it
don't ruin reacher for me man i'm
ruining reaching for you i said he hates
all races equally no i'm saying that
when you get to be like i don't know mid
40s and nothing works the way you used
to work your knees are a little shot
you're a little handpicked by that
battle axe of a wife you have like your
job is unsatisfying like the world i
think we're seeing inside of mark
bernardin right now i'm saying where it
would the the reacher is the id that
nobody gets to have anymore reach reach
is the dude who walks into a town nobody
can [ __ ] with him if you step to reach
you he's going to kill you he's not even
going to hurt you to hurt you he's going
to kill you you shoot to the back just
because
you know all the girls shot some people
came back all the guys went it was
beautiful yeah yeah that part was really
good
you sold it that way too you're like i
think you saw it on i don't know if it
was on the show on twitter or like
sometimes you just want to watch a show
where a guy settles all things by
shooting somebody in the back
and then asks you got a problem with
that they were bad guys
um i do think it's it's the power
fantasy it's what if what if the world
didn't have the mechanism to keep me
down anymore you know like every
authority
if i was [ __ ] like seven right what
if i walked into every room and everyone
was afraid of me what if every woman i
ran into wanted to sleep with me what if
i could just live untethered and
unfettered by the world i can just
travel from [ __ ] bus stop to bus stop
fighting wrongs fighting crimes and then
go to the next [ __ ] town i murder
everybody and there's no repercussions
for that there's nobody like i'm gonna
arrest that dude because even if they do
they're like oh reacher and then they'll
let you out of jail they kill more
[ __ ] dudes they put reacher in jail
so many times rightfully for taking a
life and on bizarre technicalities like
all right richard get out of that cell
like did you kill that guy yes but he
was bad all right reacher
so like it's i i understand why it is as
popular as it is yeah is it popular it's
hugely popular i'm glad you know and i'm
sorry that they're not doing your show
but i'm glad they did that show no i get
it like i also get now white people were
pissed off at tom cruise's cast oh my
god
because i like to reach her so [ __ ]
much that i was like well i'm gonna go
watch the tom cruise ones you know i've
never seen him and [ __ ] and it is
it's all the difference between like
a show that's even though it's like
fantastical as [ __ ]
somewhat grounded in reality this is a
giant man who knows how to kill in many
different ways and fight so clearly he
could do some damage
i'm not saying like people that aren't
as big as because i don't want to get
[ __ ] killed on twitter again but i'm
not saying like
people aren't as tall as alan richton
can't [ __ ] kick ass
but
the tom cruise version of reacher which
i watched they're two movies not just
one they did a second one with colby
never looked back never looked back
it's it feels more like a movie because
like
when you watch reach of the show you're
like this guy could [ __ ] kill anybody
when you watch reach of the movie you're
like oh it's a movie because they're
saying tom cruise could kill anybody
because he's facing like [ __ ] dudes
with guns bigger than him and again i'm
not like ruling out [ __ ] martial arts
and [ __ ] like that but like it's tough
it's more like a movie where you're like
this is what happens in the movies
whereas reacher you're like i think this
is a documentary like
i think this [ __ ] happened somewhere in
georgia and i'm gonna go deep diving on
the internet about georgia canada yeah
um is that where they shot it yeah
that is not georgia at all but and the
power fantasy with tom cruise isn't
there the way it is for this dude like
reacher is conan the barbarian yes i
will just run into this [ __ ] town
what's happening is there a bar i'm
going to drink i'm going to have sex i'm
going to steal some [ __ ] i'm going to
kill some people
you keep throwing sex in there and i
want you you're really [ __ ]
besmirching my boy reacher there wasn't
there was a little sex but not as much
as you're saying don't make him out to
be the american james bond where he
[ __ ] him loves him and leaves them and
[ __ ] like that richard's got a good
[ __ ] heart mark
he helped out roscoe ah i can't talk to
you anymore yeah
except that he also had to [ __ ] roscoe
because that's what your hero does i
believe if i remember the show correctly
roscoe wanted to [ __ ] him because of
course she does
have you seen that man bro i wanted to
[ __ ] him the dude's a man a mountain of
man just
[ __ ] hence the fantasy yes
yes i had fantasies of my own while i
watched the show my big fantasy was like
season two is starting next week
but why can't they [ __ ] make this
show faster than the average show
because literally it's just a dude who
walks into a town there's no special
effects and they're like look at the
[ __ ] spaceship this guy's [ __ ]
flying it's just a dude who walks into
town and beats people up all he needs is
some stunt man get that [ __ ] show
done i demand reacher a new reacher
every month
i don't see in a world it's amazon
they're not giving you the money to make
your show [ __ ] give it to reacher to
make more [ __ ] shows one per month
because they got how many books
uh
in the 20s i think oh my god
that's like 20 years of reacher i have
to look forward to
i can't wait to go home and tell my wife
like i figured out what we're doing
until we die
we're living from reacher to reacher man
watching this corn fed white boy just
demolish everybody
he's going to be so old and [ __ ]
my parents like they had a show i guess
they watched one of those like before my
old man died was csi
or nate one of those [ __ ] navy shows
on
like 20 years ago the mark carmen
[ __ ] ncis
that was the one that they would watch
together like my mom still talks about
it she's like oh me and your father
watch
ncis or whatever the [ __ ] and
it was it was in the way where i was
like mom did you want to [ __ ] mark
harmon like why why are you so into the
show but it was connected to dad yeah
yeah it was the i get maybe after the
show dad was like let's do it maybe
that's when he got laid he was like i
loved ncis night holy [ __ ]
n-c-i-s-e-x yes ncis-6
come on grace take off that [ __ ]
uniform
do they wear uniforms on that show i
don't know
why are they in the military
and they're a branch of the military
that you don't have to wear [ __ ] the
outfit because then i might have joined
the uniform i was keeping you out the
only thing i was like i can't wear that
catholic school navy nope not doing
either makes me look fat
uh i've never seen ncis really yeah
we'll drop it here
fair enough um so yeah so michelle got
killed sorry uh which is all right
because uh creature lives reacher lives
and i achieved picture lock on my short
film oh [ __ ] yes
[Applause]
[Music]
splinter short splinter shot
locked you happy with the cup i'm happy
with the cut thank you for your notes
kevin gave me some very thoughtful
suggestions i did yes i took some of
them i was yeah i wasn't like you gotta
do all this but i was like this is what
i would do and it was like you made yoga